[Music]
welcome back
okay so this is uh one of the
culminating points of
the series on complex analysis in
particular this kind of integral portion
where we're looking at how to do
integrals of functions in the complex
plane functions that are analytic or
functions that are non-analytic
and this cauchy integral formula is one
of that
kind of the high water marks of this
theory it's super super useful and it
synthesizes some of the things we've
learned earlier
and i think the next lecture after this
one we're going to get into some super
hairy integrals basically how do you
solve gnarly integrals using everything
i taught you
and
specifically how do we use
uh these integrals in the complex plane
to solve for practical things like you
know the inverse laplace transform
integral the brom which uh the brahm
which integral that we use to solve for
the inverse laplace transform so this is
kind of uh a good waypoint uh in the
part on uh
on integral
integrals of functions in the complex
plane
so cauchy integral formula says
essentially
if we have an analytic function f f of z
so
if
f of z
is analytic
analytic we know what analytic functions
are we can do derivatives
um they have convergent taylor series
they're well behaved functions if it's
analytic
uh inside and on
inside and on
a closed curve c a simple closed curve c
a simple
closed curve c
this just means uh
[Music]
basically i actually mean that the the
domain that this curve c is on is
simple meaning that uh the domain is is
one connected region it doesn't have two
disconnected regions in the domain of
analogicity
but if f of z is analytic inside and on
a closed curve c
and
if i have a point a is inside
c so
this point a is inside my closed curve
my close curve c
then the following integral formula is
true and the following integral formula
is that the integral the closed integral
around this contour c and again the
convention is to go counterclockwise the
reason
is because counterclockwise again
this is historical kind of when you
write textbooks you would think of the
the orientation that makes the most
sense
and going
counterclockwise if i integrated a
logarithm or a one over z minus a
that would be what would cause me to go
up the spiral logarithmic staircase to
gain positive two pi i of phase whereas
if i had this going in the clockwise
direction i'd be going down uh and
spiraling you know and that's we don't
want to go in a downward spiral so
this convention is to do a clock
counterclockwise curve c so the koshi
integral formula says that if i do a
contour integral uh over an
anti-clockwise
contour c that contains this point a
of f of z
over z minus a d z remember f of z is
analytic so if it was not divided by z
minus a then this integral would equal
zero
but because i have kind of manually
multiplied this by one over z minus a
which remember is the only kind of you
know
function one over z minus a that if i do
an integral around its singular point i
actually pick up two pi i of phase
that's what we showed in the last
lecture
this integral equals
2 pi i
times the function f evaluated at that
point a
so this doesn't seem implausible but it
also doesn't seem obvious it's it
doesn't seem at all implausible that
this could be true we know that if f of
z was 1 and i had integral of 1 over z
minus a i would have 2 pi i
that's what we showed in the last
lecture
essentially because that would give you
a logarithm and if i integrated that
logarithm over a closed orbit i would
gain a 2 pi i of phase
so it's not entirely implausible that i
would evaluate f at that point a but
it's also not entirely obvious so this
is kind of a
very important uh
important
formula an important theorem
and i'm going to show you why this is
true it's actually pretty easy to show
good
simple to derive so let's see how to do
this
so this is pretty simple
to derive
don't drink and derive
so you have the integral of
f of z
over z minus a d z and what we're going
to do is we're going to break this up
into two integrals in kind of a cutesy
way so what we're going to do is we're
going to say that this equals
the integral
of
f of a
over z minus a
dz
plus the
integral
of f of z minus f of a
over z minus a dz now it seems like how
could this possibly be benefiting me i'm
literally just taking my integral and
i'm saying okay well it's f of z minus f
of a plus f of a i've just added you
know i've subtracted f of a here and
i've added f of a here seems like you
know i didn't really do anything but
what we're going to be able to show
is that this function adds up to 0 and
this of course is equal to 2 pi i f
of a
so we're going to call this integral
integral 1
and we're going to call this integral
integral 2
and i'm going to solve each of them
separately and that's what we're going
to do this one's trivial because f of a
is a constant
and so i can move that constant outside
of the integral and the integral
of 1 over z minus a over a closed loop
containing a is 2 pi i
so the integral
integral 1
is obviously equal to f a
you know integral of one over z minus a
d z
equals f of a two pi i which of course
is what we
are expecting so that's good
and so all i have to do is show that
this integral i two equals 0
and i have you know proven what i need
to prove
so now we need to show that i 2 equals
0.
so to show
i 2 equals 0 what we're going to do is
we are going to deform this contour c
we're going to deform
c
into
this thing i'm going to call c delta
which basically is shrink wrapped around
that point a we're going to kind of hug
that point a and take the limit as that
radius goes to 0
of this c delta so we're going to define
this
curve
c
delta
and again because the function
f of z
and f of z over z minus a actually that
whole function is analytic everywhere
except z
equals a
remember f is analytic and one over z
minus a is analytic everywhere except z
equals a
then i can by the koshi gorsa theorem i
can deform my contour all the way down
until it's super duper close to that
point as long as i don't cross through
it as long as i don't cross through a
singularity the function is analytic
everywhere outside of that point a and
so i can deform this thing down as close
as i like to that point a
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to basically take the limit as
delta goes to zero the kind of radius
goes to zero and prove that this equals
zero so that's what i'm going to do now
and this is going to rely on a kind of
idea from calculus that i'm pretty sure
almost all of you have heard of you
might not really remember it
this idea that we have kind of delta
epsilon proofs okay this if i have a
continuous function
and analytic functions are basically
continuous on steroids
um
so if i have a continuous function
then i can use kind of these delta
epsilon proofs uh to bound the behavior
and the rate of change of my function in
neighborhoods so since
f
of z is analytic
analytic
around a around
this point a
we can choose we can
choose
a delta a delta
so that such that we can choose a delta
such that
uh f of z
minus f of a
is less than epsilon so this is a
standard delta epsilon idea from
continuous function theory from real
value calculus that we're used to
is that because f z is analytic around a
near a
what this means is that f z and remember
f z is actually analytic at a f of z is
analytic at a around a f of z is
analytic everywhere inside of c it's
only this one over z minus a that's not
analytic so f of z is analytic at a
and so what that means is that as i get
really really really close
to that point a for that radius delta
for any epsilon i like no matter how
small this is if this is 0.001 or 0.0001
whatever i choose epsilon to be i can
find a delta close enough that f of z
minus f of z of a is within that epsilon
that's a delta epsilon proof
so i can choose a delta a radius that's
close enough to a that this is true for
any small epsilon greater than zero
and so essentially what that means is
that uh my integral 2
which is the integral uh around c delta
of f of z
minus f of a over z minus a d z
equals now this implies that the norm of
i2
is going to be less than or equal
to
the norm of this thing which is less
than epsilon so this whole norm is going
to be less than or equal to the integral
of epsilon over z minus a d z this is
kind of like that ml bound i was showing
you
and
this is going to equal 2 pi i epsilon
but this was true for any epsilon i
could find a delta that makes this with
an epsilon so i can take the limit as
epsilon goes to zero and i just can find
that i i basically there is a delta that
will that will if i constrict delta to
zero this epsilon will go to zero so
this is true
for
all epsilon greater than zero so it has
to equal zero so this has to equal zero
that's kind of cool we let epsilon go to
zero and this integral has to equal zero
and so this i two integral which started
out on this big curve c but i could
continuously deform it down by koshi
gorsa to c delta
we have proven that if we make that
delta infinitesimally small then this
integral
will also get infinitesimally small so
i2 goes to zero
and so the only thing that's left is i1
which is f evaluated at a times two pi i
which is the cauchy integral formula
okay
very very cool very very important um
uh important
formula or property of functions in the
complex plane this comes up all over the
place you should just you know first off
remember that it's true remember the
cauchy integral formula remember why
it's true
you know f of z is analytic and this one
over z minus a always picks up a two pi
i phase when you integrate around a
closed orbit containing a
and then you know kind of trust yourself
to be able to derive these things when
you need them using things like the
koshi integral formula and the ml bound
right these are things that should be
eventually if you get enough practice
pretty
you should become pretty facile with
and i actually have my students either
do an exercise or i do this live in
class either in you know python or
matlab or whatever programming language
you like
is you can actually
you can actually kind of confirm that
you pick up this two pi i phase and you
can do this for other functions
you can basically
[Music]
discretely create
a
you can discretely integrate around a
circle by breaking this up into d thetas
which is basically 2
pi divided by n
let's say n equals one thousand so n
equals one thousand you make d theta
equals two pi over n
and then for k equals one to n for k
equals one
to n
you go around the circle
you add up
the complex number e to the i theta you
say z equals e to the i
theta uh you know you define theta
equals um
you would say
theta equals k
times d theta for i for k equals one to
n
z equals e to the i theta
and you could do dz
equals i e to the i theta
and you would essentially integrate
um
you know you would integrate up that
function let's say you know f equals one
over z or one over z squared or sine of
z i guess what i'm trying to get at and
i hope um you know i'll put a little
link to a code in here i'm pretty sure i
have a matlab and a python code for this
what i'm getting at is that you can
numerically evaluate these integrals you
can basically chop up you can
continuously deform your contour so that
it's a circle of constant radius equals
one make your life easier and then you
can break up your theta into n little
pieces and you can actually add up that
function f of z over z minus a you know
times d theta in that closed orbit and
you will find numerically that you get 2
pi i times f of a like this will pop out
of your numerical integration scheme
that you write and you can verify this
for lots of analytic functions f of z
you know e to the z
z squared the constant function f of z
equals one and you'll kind of get some
real good intuition uh for how this
stuff works
okay uh what's coming up next is three
hairy integral lectures so um
i'm not sure how to feel about that
i've got mixed feelings it's
calm okay so i'm going to show you how
to use all of this stuff
to compute
really nasty integrals both real valued
integrals and complex integrals and
we're going to simplify them and use
these kind of tricks i've shown you ml
bounds and koshi gorsa and koshi
integral formula to solve those hairy
integrals
and the kind of last hairy integral i'm
going to show you is the bromwich
integral which is what we do to solve
for the inverse laplace transform so if
you really want to know how this stuff
works if you really want to understand
you know what is the guts of an inverse
laplace transform or if you want to be
really good at solving you know complex
or real value definite integrals
you know at cocktail parties
you're gonna need the next three hairy
lectures um
but you can skip them if you don't all
right thank you